what's up all you cool cats and kittens
it's uh programming meme review time
because it's always
programming meme review time after a
thousand new followers
swarming into the channel you guys just
coming in watching my vids and i
appreciate you so i asked what you
wanted to see you guys said programming
meme reviews please so bringing you the
meme reviews these are the ones i have
saved i'm gonna go over all the ones
i've saved that i thought or some part
of me at one point thought they were
worth saving
so disclaimer but also i'll review some
new ones too so let's let's review these
programming memes i've done this a bunch
and you know i give my honest take on
these and tell you the real scenarios
because a lot of these memes are like
not even accurate oh let's get it done
memes i have saved okay let's move the
kick in a little side profile all right
let's go all right so i'm just gonna
open these up full screen is bad boy and
we'll flip through this is not a meme
this is just an fyi that i thought was
cool free software alternatives you get
these kind of questions a lot anytime
like any time i make anything with
blender or there's always people like
but which one should i use and the
answer is i don't care why would i care
what you use i'm just some youtuber
that's not actually a youtuber because i
don't get actually paid enough to be to
consider myself a youtuber so uh maybe
consider supporting my channel and i'll
consider being a youtuber but for now
i'm just some dude that makes videos
occasionally and makes like a hundred
bucks a month but it costs way more than
that to make videos so i'm literally
paying
hundreds sometimes thousands of dollars
to produce these videos out of pocket
and not seeing returns so yeah i don't
consider myself a youtuber i don't know
why so many people listen to me do what
you want done
in general i don't know why people
listen to people so often do your own
research figure out your own thing oh
but what if i learn davinci resolve and
then i go work for a company and they
use premiere pro i don't care and also
there's a lot of overlap if you learn
one you're going to know the other
pretty well things are just in different
spots they're called different things
but they're using the same algorithms
and functions generally so
stop being a bunch of pansies that's
what i'm going to say
and uh let's go to the next one oh let's
zoom in all right why programmers always
prefer dark mode cause light attracts
bugs yeah that's really corny i can tell
you that just programming in general
attracts bugs of all sorts
error on line 42 line 42's blank
okay generally when you see this it's
the line before you forgot to end it
properly so there's like a new line i i
don't know who knows really this is just
a meme but sometimes this is what it's
like you get an error
it's not quite what it says it is so you
have to like unravel
what it actually is and that can be
tricky especially for new coders but if
it doesn't make sense look at the lines
right before the error or the stuff
right before the error that's my only
suggestion all right next quote of the
day don't cling to a mistake just
because you spent a lot of time making
it yeah that that can relate
a lot if you guys watch my channel
you'll get it but if you don't
you won't
is it true should you cling to a mistake
no that's that's a lot to unpack this
isn't even a cody meme but like
obviously uh well like i'm making a
little game engine and it's not exactly
successful
does that mean i should give up no
i i don't know how to actually uh relate
this to anything i'm just moving on i
don't think this is actually that kind
of quote it's not as good as you would
think but it's it's more for like i
don't know what is this for
relationships i guess like you hooked up
with the wrong person and
i don't even know how to apply this
quote anymore
new senior joins the team nice
i junior answers questions on a code
base i wrote yeah if you wrote it then
okay i review his pr's i find
inefficiency and redundancies in his
code due to my acknowledge that the code
base he implements my various feedback
and i approve his pr's it sounds like
you're the senior and he's the junior
and your company's just not that bright
or not that good or recognizing talent
when they see it so
either go talk to your boss and be like
look i know all this stuff way better
than the senior i should be a senior and
if they say no you say all right i'm
gonna go work somewhere else where i
could be a senior dad when i got all
this experience thank you for giving me
the experience but also beep you for
not appreciating me so that's what you
do terrible meme
uh well it's a good example of what not
to do
all right let's move to the next one
next one
me runs command linux nope not gonna do
that let me put sudo before the command
linux i did not expect that power it's
kind of funny
do i need to explain the meme sudo is
super user do and you have to put in an
admin credentials or root credentials or
something
and it just does whatever you tell it to
do so yes you can break your system if
you want to you can tell delete files
that shouldn't be deleted with sudo and
i'm sure most of you already know that
but
sometimes i look at these and maybe i'm
just in a bitter sour mood which to be
honest i kind of am and
i'm just trying to play it off i have
more reasons all right but this is like
such common sense and so obvious that
there's no cleverness to this kind of
meme i give it a one one out of ten
that's the lowest ranking
all right bro work related question for
you his job is slashing this was just
like to flex on other people like why
not use python
is that even something that i can
address that's
okay like why not just use python well
because it's slower so if you care about
performance you see plus plus duh
right i mean if you're a programmer you
already know this java i don't know why
people use java because they're forced
to at some point and they get used to it
that's why they use java i guess uh
yeah you know i'm a sequel's plus coder
so i'm a little biased
but i've used python i've used java you
see plus plus the one that seemed like
the obvious one to learn deeply was c
plus plus the others are just like they
have their uses but in general the one
to really understand is the deepest one
all right
no one is coming to save you your life
is 100 your responsibility
no comment all right client why don't
you understand my requirements this
requirement
uh that's when you said oh i understand
them it's just not something that works
like what would this be in code like uh
if you had to think about i guess they
could say like i want you to get like an
mmo with graphics better than wow and
all the dark souls and better than eldon
ring on running on a raspberry pi that's
my requirements that's
yeah clients are often not aware of how
things work they just want to see
results
so
i don't know if i have any super insight
on it this is pretty funny though i love
the picture all right here we go
don't shoot i'm a programmer prove it
array start at one
blah blah blah
okay how's it even know what an array is
most people don't know what arrays are
unless they're programmers let's pause
for a moment of science for our fellow
lua programmers rip arrays still start
at zero even in any language just behind
the scenes lua made changes that's what
i would guess anyway i don't usually
that much but
when lua actually does the thing behind
the scenes to your memory and everything
it's still starting at zero so he's he's
technically wrong and lou is technically
wrong still all right
all of the internet infrastructure and
free software yeah there are a lot of
really nice libraries that hold up a lot
of things that people aren't aware of
every once in a while you get these uh
fake alpha chads that are like bro just
use proprietary stuff it's well
supported and it never breaks yeah right
you know what most of the proprietary
stuff is built on free software free
libraries
yeah it's true
go look go check you'll learn you'll
find out junior devs not documenting
code forgetting how it works
senior devs clean code extensive
documentation help files read these
forget house
kind of accurate yeah i i feel this
because there's a lot of times where uh
i'll put elaborate documentation not a
lot of times just sometimes and then
i'll go back to like read it later i'm
like this is way too much to read i'm
just going to jump in and i still
i don't know if documentation actually
helps that much i think it's better to
really study the code and understand how
it works it doesn't i guess it doesn't
hurt to have comments and stuff it
doesn't hurt doesn't
in this case it looks like it hurts
because you go through all these hurdles
to do this extra stuff and you still
have the same problem
but
i don't know that's like that's
it's so situational who really knows all
right developer returns to game after
four decades discover say typo discovers
and fixes typo so it works for decades
that's a game made in the like what the
70s no way
no way but i feel this there's
definitely a lot of old repos i have
that if i like looked at them now and
spent time on them i'd be like what was
i thinking this could be so much better
i could fix all this up now but it's
like
time
time is knowledge sort of
all right me adding useless comments to
my code can't have dirty garbage
i don't know why i saved this
i don't get the reference to dirty
garbage i know what they mean but it
doesn't really make sense because it's
like adding comments to code is not
cleaning anything because they're saying
like oh my coat's garbage let me add
some comments and i'm cleaning it but
it's that's not cleaning it it's just
adding comments so what do you mean by
can't have dirty garbage
i guess it's just a spongebob they're
trying to really spongebob failure one
of one of ten least
lowest ranking you can get yeah least
lowest
thank you doctor you did your best any
doctors oh any doctor here i'm a doctor
what's going on a heart attack i'm a
doctor of computer science he is going
to die old man.set health 100 oh my god
so that's he's not there's no way he's a
doctor of computer science because
he's setting it to a string called a
hundred percent which
it's some ascii random numbers it's not
a hundred percent even it's just like
here's some characters that aren't
actually numbers
absolute epic failure thank you meme
maker you did your best but this is you
failed to me that's not how you would
set health to a hundred percent
well you could but then you have to
abstract it and to reading each of these
four characters one to zero the zero the
percent
and then a null character to terminate
it and you have to change each one of
those from a character into a float or
an integer
and parse it kind of like compiling
every time you run your function you do
not want to be compiling every time you
run a function you just want it to do
its thing this is terrible code yes he's
definitely going to die that's not even
going to set his health 100 even if you
were cody and if you're doing it that
way rethink your life
choose a different career go back to
school i don't know
but
this is not a good meme
wow we're getting there guys
there's gotta be at least one good one
all right learning javascript is like
looking both ways before you cross the
street and then getting hit by an
airplane
what does that even mean like i get it i
get what he means he's trying to bash
javascript
but what's what's the actual problem
here if you do web development you kind
of gotta learn javascript that has
nothing to do with looking both ways or
crossing the street getting hit by an
airplane i don't get it
programming memes are terrible even the
ones i save that i think that i feel
like we're good at one point i look at
later and realize how
like they don't even make sense they're
just like oh let's bash javascript oh
let's let's pretend you can call
function to set things to 100 except we
don't even do it in a way that
programmers would even do it
come on get out of here jeez that's all
that's what i got saved god this were
bad
it's time for me to go cry all right
maybe we can find some good ones on
reddit maybe let's have a look all right
we've made it to the old programmer
humor let's see what we got shall we
github being passed aggressive okay get
up i know my bills are
you know but
don't no need to be passive aggressive
about build failed just like the
previous build oh that's kind of funny
that's better than most of them so far
i'll give you that i'll give you that
all right everywhere i go to start i
need you to become familiar with our
repo great where can i find the
documentation there is documentation
right
yeah there should be there should be
something is this a thing do people
really not document that much i mean
you know i try to but i might be a
little guilty in fact i just finished
documenting the whole public front end a
little game engine thingy so there is
documentation now
you get me this time there is
documentation all right
based on true story news so okay we
already saw that one cell as an editor
vim notepad
simple student excel yeah that's
terrible it wouldn't even work you could
like export as comma separated values
and remove all the commas i guess
but
i feel like vim should be down here
though and like all the good editors
should be up here scared of it because
vim's the actual one you need to be
terrified in my experience good luck
good luck losing all your code i mean
every time it crashes them why do people
still use them
i don't know to be like that centering
div with css
moving on
last year i got rejected
during a job interview for not
understanding the concepts of a certain
ios library what the interviewer didn't
know i wrote that thing i actually had a
lot of fun during that interview then
how did you fail the interview i don't
okay
so let's just analyze this for a second
in theory anyone could show up to some
interview about something they're an
expert on and just completely troll the
interview and pretend like they don't
know what it is even though they do but
what why would you do that what is the
point
that's not even a funny joke
i don't get it
see what i wonder is
oh he's got this laughy face at the end
crying like was he actually trying and
his way of explaining was just so bad
that the interviewer was like this guy
doesn't
know or was he trolling the interviewer
and pretending he didn't know i i don't
get i don't get why you would waste your
time
doing that in an interview unless you're
literally going there with like a hidden
camera and trying to get content or
something but even that's still a jerk
move so all right well
i don't i don't even know how to
interpret this but apparently people
think it's funny i just think it's
pathetic basically all right call your
functions why isn't my function running
call it
yeah no crap why is that a meme or funny
i
might miss something here i swear i've
done a lot of these meme reviews and
this happens every time i get in and
start digging into them and i realize
that they don't even like they're not
even memes they're just like
people saying really basic obvious stuff
that you just would know if you're a
programmer and thinking it's funny but
it's not it's just
it's just unintelligible i don't want to
do this anymore quick guys
you